the clark county school district is
considering mandatory coveted vaccines
for its staff a special board meeting
will take place next wednesday evening
madison kimbrough joins us live from
ccsd headquarters she spoke to parents
today regarding this potential policy
change madison
mixed reaction from parents this
afternoon as ccsd announces a possible
vaccination requirement for its staff
the special meeting will be held at the
clark county government center the board
will consider a resolution allowing
superintendent dr jesus jarrah to
establish a policy for vaccinations
several school districts throughout the
u.s have made the decision to vaccinate
staff and with so many children still
not old enough to be vaccinated this is
a step to control the spread i spoke to
several families today about this
possible requirement
i feel better knowing that my kid is
safe at school knowing that the people
that are handling him all day long are
all vaccinated and safe as well well i
don't think the masks are worn properly
so i don't i don't think it's
that changes much especially kids who
are constantly touching
their face and everything else around it
but um i think vaccinations are more
going to be what helps them
if this is approved the school district
would have to also consider exemption
requests for medical or religious
reasons also the draft resolution does
not include a timeline for when staff
would need to be vaccinated
currently those staff members that are
not vaccinated are required to test
weekly showing proof of a negative test
again this meeting is set for next
wednesday at 5 p-m reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now thank you
madison and we did ask those of you on
twitter are you for or against the
school board approving that policy 70
percent in favor of mandatory
vaccinations among school staff 30
percent who weighed in opposed